[Music]
on this thursday night
hospitals pushed to the brink
an acceleration in admissions that could
lead to cancelled surgeries
we have to avoid the worst case scenario
at all costs
stark messaging in the us do not travel
for thanksgiving
with exponential growth of covid19 is it
too little
too late and the pandemic's painful toll
in europe that is one person dying
every 17 seconds another scathing report
about the rcmp
i still hear from women all the time who
are in some level of hell in the rcmp
the toxic and hateful culture and
questions about whether it can ever
change plus surprise stowaway
the tiny owl rescued from the
rockefeller center christmas tree
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we were warned earlier this fall of the
possible consequences of a second wave
now it's happening with case numbers
surging across much of canada hospital
beds are filling up
and dozens of canadians are dying from
the virus every day
you only have to look south to see what
happens when the virus spreads out of
control
across the us hospital icu's are filling
up
they're running out of staff morgues are
running out of room
here in canada we have not reached that
point but in hot spots the situation is
deteriorating fast
in ontario in just the last week the
number of people in intensive care
jumped 49 percent
according to the ontario hospital
association there are now 150 coveted
patients in
icu the government had warned that 150
was the limit for icus
after that other surgeries would have to
be canceled
the human toll is rising
we listen to the number of people in the
intensive care unit these people are
extremely
unwell and and it's it's really
important to remember
that while we talk about numbers as said
these are individuals in manitoba
the whole province is already in the red
zone the test positivity right there is
14 percent
eight more people died today and
hospitalizations are surging
the province's top doctors said they had
no choice but to impose even tighter
restrictions on people's lives
as of midnight manitobans cannot enter a
house they don't live in
and businesses can only sell essential
items in store
remember that the right to shop is not
as important as the right to life
and we're bringing these difficult
measures forward today to protect people
stay home don't socialize with people
outside your household
and leave for essential reasons only and
in bc
sweeping new restrictions are coming
into force starting today and
until december 7th the entire province
is being told not to meet with anyone
outside their household
all community events are suspended
enforcement of public health orders is
being stepped up
and the province's top doctor is urging
people to stop
non-essential travel so now we need
to do more we need to keep our essential
service
our essential activities open and
operating safely
we need to keep our schools open and
operating
safely and our workplaces that can be
open safely open and we need to relieve
the stress
on our health care system right now
global's keith baldry has details about
the new restrictions
keith yes donna with the virus surging
in british columbia public health
officials taking measures to control the
gathering of people for social occasions
basically extending throughout the
entire province a public health order
that was brought down last week
forbidding people from visiting each
other's homes you've got to stay within
your own household
another big move announced today is the
mandatory mask wearing will now be
required in retail establishments that's
been a hot button issue
in british columbia and other
jurisdictions as well for so for the
next two weeks you have to wear a mask
if you go into a retail
establishment also no religious services
to be offered for the next two weeks in
churches in temples
significant moves for around the
province to try to contain the surge of
this virus which is now tracking
upwards of 700 cases a day donna
all right keith baldry in victoria
tonight thanks the premier of quebec is
proposing a plan to allow families
to gather over christmas fresh while ago
says groups of up to 10 people will be
allowed to get together
over a four-day period but only if they
self-isolate for a week before and a
week after
that means students will have to learn
from home for several days before the
holiday
we'll need strength to get through
this pandemic and to find this strength
we need our families
other provinces have considered
extending the winter break for schools
there have been cases of covid19 inside
schools but
often it is people who have been
infected in the community
transmission inside schools themselves
is limited
and keeping kids home the way new york
city has can lead to other problems
mike derlay reports on what we know at
this stage of the pandemic
morning any people with ontario caught
in the undertow of the second wave of
covet 19
talk has turned to the possibility of
another lockdown
and the one untouchable for most parents
schools
it's a disaster for parents who have to
rearrange their whole schedules
to take care of their kids when you know
they should be in school
the debate has turned ugly in new york
city which closed its schools when the
city's positivity rate hit 3 percent
a decision largely considered to be
politically fueled
toronto's rate by comparison is at six
percent
yet there's no debate for ontario
premier doug ford
the safest place for our children right
now are actually
in in the schools outside the schools is
another matter entirely
with positivity numbers in and around
toronto hitting record highs
one peel region neighborhood has topped
20 percent
and health officials are concerned with
the recent positivity rate spike
among high school and university age
students
overall 14 percent of ontario's schools
have seen at least one case but what the
numbers don't say
is that the vast majority of those cases
were acquired in the community
not the schools so the science supports
keeping schools open but health
officials are keeping a close eye on two
areas
community outbreaks and hospital
capacity
dr ray watt dianandin says there's a
threshold
where the recommendation will change if
it looks like we are getting to the
stage where hallway medicine
is a norm and there's no sign of
diminishment
then we should strongly consider taking
all super spreading opportunities off
the table including schools
the good news for parents is the ontario
government has made it clear
keeping schools open is a priority
microlight global news toronto
to other news now another review of the
rcmp has reached a scathing conclusion
the independent review by former supreme
court justice michelle basterash
concludes
the culture of the rcmp is toxic and
tolerates misogynistic
and homophobic attitudes more than three
thousand people came forward with
detailed stories of assault
bullying and despair many of them
received compensation through a class
action lawsuit that paid out more than
125 million dollars
today's report is called broken dreams
broken lives
and some of the details are disturbing
it says the problems are so deep in
systemic that
fundamental change cannot come from
within the force
carolyn jarvis reports their stories
include horrific accounts of sexual
assault
degrading comments and unwelcome
touching
acts that occurred over decades to more
than 2 300 women who worked for the rcmp
the level of violence and sexual assault
that was reported
was shocking writes justice bastarash in
his report
over 130 claimants disclose penetrative
sexual assaults after all our work and
all our fighting
here it is bound and brutal
for many the harassment haunts them to
this day
it's not just that their careers were
shattered their lives were shattered
their relationships were destroyed their
ability to work
was destroyed the reports says there
were women who sat with their service
revolvers in their mouths and were only
stopped from killing themselves when
they thought of their children or their
pets
another rcmp employee who filed the
claim for the settlement
did die by suicide i still hear from
women all the time
who who are in some level of hell in the
rcmp
and there's a potent minority within the
force that's
ruining that organization in the
strongest language
justice bastarash says the rcmp has
proven incapable of fixing itself
the time has come for an in-depth
external and independent review of the
organization
the forces commissioner wouldn't address
that recommendation head on
but denounced the behavior there is no
place
in my organization for discrimination
sexual assault harassment bullying
sexism racism homophobia or transphobia
it will
not be tolerated and employees will be
held to account
the rcmp announced it will open a center
for harassment resolution next summer
staffed by civilians but the concern for
some
including justice bastarash is that the
issues within the rcmp
are so entrenched it may take breaking
up the force
to end it carolyn jarvis global news
toronto and it's important to note the
lawsuit is one of two significant class
action settlements related to
gender-based harassment inside the rcmp
the other is for non-policing employees
within the force
that settlement is accepting claims
until january 12th
to some breaking news from ontario
tonight a police officer and a civilian
are
dead after a shooting it happened on
manitoulin island in lake huron about
six hours northwest of toronto
investigators say police were sent to
investigate an unwanted man
on a property in gore bay police say
constable mark hoving a 28-year veteran
of the ontario provincial police
was shot when he got there police say a
man
on the property was also shot and died
after he was taken to the hospital
the federal environment minister has
introduced legislation that sets targets
for emission reduction
plans that in theory would fulfill a
promise made in the last election
the liberals vowed to be more aggressive
at cutting greenhouse gas emissions and
get canada to net zero emissions by 2050
but canada has set multiple goals for
curbing emissions and has not met
any of them so is this proposed law
going to do it
as abigail beeman reports the ambitious
plan lacks detail
making canada net zero by 2050 an
ambitious goal
now legally binding at least on paper
bill c-12
lays out a framework of accountability
and transparency
that will ensure we reach this goal in a
way that gives canadians
confidence how they plan to do it
remains a mystery
the new bill is based around five year
milestones the government has to set an
emissions reduction target
and a plan to achieve it every five
years but the first milestone isn't
until 2030
and we don't know the plan to get there
either we have committed to
exceeding our 2030 targets there is no
plan
for getting us to net zero
there is very little accountability and
it's really just a game of smoke and
mirrors there are no legal consequences
for missing a target
still environmental groups call
legislating net zero a big step forward
this government has its work cut out for
it not only does it need to improve this
piece of accountability legislation
but it needs to be working on a strong
climate action plan
that makes sure that we stop breaking
our promises to the world
the liberals made the net zero promise
during the last federal election
campaign and were defensive then about a
lack of details
i'm not going to stand here and say what
our exact plan is to 2050 because we
need to make that plan with experts
while creating an expert task force is
also now enshrined in law
it doesn't yet exist if they consult
directly with the oiling ong
industry i think there may be some novel
ideas
coming forward from that that group
on how to in fact reduce emissions the
prime minister wouldn't answer why he
doesn't have a 2025 target
environmentalists are calling for one
and while the government has given
itself
up to nine months after the bill passes
to offer
details on the 2030 targets the
environment minister is promising more
details in a matter of weeks
abigail beeman global news ottawa
canada is one of a number of nations
promising to be carbon neutral by the
middle of the century
climate change has been eclipsed by the
more immediate crisis of the corona
virus but it doesn't mean political
leaders can take their foot off the
accelerator
and now political change in the u.s is
spurring many nations to renew their
calls
to take action eric sorenson reports
japan's parliament today declared a
climate emergency
the vote those who stood shows a
dramatic consensus on this global crisis
britain this week moved up a ban on
gasoline-fueled cars to 2030
and the world's largest carbon emitter
china promises to be carbon neutral by
2060
and called this month for greater
international cooperation
that opportunity may be at hand
above all global leaders see the
election of a new u.s president
as an opportunity to accelerate climate
action it is time
for a new transatlantic agenda fit for
today's world
we all have a collective responsibility
there i see common ground
the change in washington couldn't be
more stark from this
we saved our oil industry and now it's
very vibrant to get
to a new message by 2050 the united
states will be
100 percent clean energy economy
with net zero emissions joe biden is
proposing a two
trillion dollar plan to shift from oil
and coal towards wind and other
renewables
and no country more than canada is
positioned to take advantage of
cross-border cooperation on clean energy
canadian workers and their families are
going to benefit
from clean growth having a biden harris
administration
in the u.s provides that you know
friendly
almost competition to be able to seize
the opportunities that
this low-carbon economy sector
represents
canada faces homegrown challenges in
going green as a major carbon producer
but the change in washington like
biden's plan to rejoin the paris climate
agreement
is refocusing much of the world above
all climate change boris johnson seems
more than ready for joe biden he wants
to
join us next year in
leading the world in getting global
greenhouse emissions down as the world
takes new steps to reduce carbon
emissions
it also welcomes america's re-engagement
on climate change
eric sorensen global news toronto
americans urged to stay home for
thanksgiving coming up the serious
warning of aggressive and
unrelenting community spread
a week before american thanksgiving and
the u.s centers for disease control
is finally telling people to stay home
big gatherings will add fuel to what's
already a raging fire
there are now an average of 160 000 new
cases
every day in the u.s hospitalizations
have hit an all-time high nearly 80
thousand
and yesterday over 1800 americans died
jackson proskow on the latest
projections of where the u.s is headed
in their first public briefing since
july members of the white house
coronavirus task force painted a grim
picture this is more cases more rapidly
than what we had seen before
since the last task force briefing
another 120 thousand americans have died
this internal white house document shows
the areas with the highest rate of cases
and warns of aggressive unrelenting
community spread across the entire
country
i believe the day is coming soon when we
will put this coronavirus in the past
the surge in cases is so rapid the
centers for disease control is warning
americans not to travel for the
thanksgiving holiday
typically the busiest travel time of the
year when you have so much virus
circulating in the community everybody
needs to do their part to
stay home unless it's absolutely
necessary it's necessary to go out
in idaho doctors warn they'll soon face
tough choices about who they can treat
as they face a dire shortage of hospital
beds we may be
facing that scenario
in december the mayo clinic reports 900
of its staff have contracted the virus
in the past
two weeks the situation risks spiraling
out of control in multiple states
but not everyone is on board with public
health measures all they're trying to do
is
control you everything you do is based
on the mask and the disease
and it's wrong in south dakota where the
positivity rate is one of the highest in
the world
the governor refuses to implement a mask
mandate i don't want to approach a
policy or a mandate
just looking to make people feel good
experts say that lack of a unified
national response is what makes the
prolonged silence from the white house
so dangerous
at a time when the u.s needs leadership
the most it's been hard to find
donna okay jackson prosco in washington
thanks
ahead hospitals in europe close to the
breaking points
much of europe is in the grip of a
second wave of covid19 now the world
health organization says europe now
accounts for 28 percent of cases in the
world and
26 of all deaths crystal gomencing
reports
intensive care units in switzerland are
at capacity
geneva university hospital is shuttling
patients
to other facilities
the hospital director says we are still
in a situation that puts the health care
system
under a lot of pressure and they're not
alone
icus in france have been at 95 percent
capacity
for the past 10 days spain and italy are
also seeing more
critically ill patients last week
europe registered over 29 000
new covet 19 deaths that is
one person dying every 17 seconds
in the european region dr hound's clue
is urging people to stick with
protective measures
your country community family and
friends
need you like they have never needed you
before
he says only about 60 percent of the
european population
is wearing a mask in a move that could
increase numbers spain's health minister
reduced the price of face coverings
to 62 cents with transmission rates out
of control
millions of people are living with
restrictions
england should be moving out of lockdown
on december 2nd
but christmas could change that there's
talk
household mixing might be allowed over
the holidays
but that could extend the lockdown into
january
saying to families you can have a you
know a reasonably normal family
christmas
but then putting restrictions in place
which may well impact their livelihoods
i don't think he's going to be a very
welcome christmas present
right now a third of european countries
are reporting
very high infection rates of more than
700 cases
per 100 thousand people crystal
commansing global news
london up next an unexpected traveler in
the time
of covid
when i got started in tv news i thought
it was a bit silly to put cute animal
stories at the end of the news well
i'm much older now and covered in
everything so
now i crave cute animal stories the one
tonight is not a partridge in a pear
tree but
it's close this tiny owl was found stuck
inside the rockefeller center christmas
tree in new york city a construction
worker spotted it
rescued it put it in a cardboard box and
it's now recovering at a wildlife rehab
center
it's a northern sawet the smallest owl
in north america
workers say they did check the tree for
wildlife before they wrapped it but they
didn't spot the little owl
it went three days with no water or food
but it's now had a buffet
of mice and is said to be doing well
it's been named
rockefeller and it's outshining the
christmas tree itself which let's face
it looks a little
ragged new yorkers say it's a metaphor
for 2020 and that is global national for
this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is lilliwette bc
we'd love to see your canada please send
it to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye